okay so uh unfortunately due to a minor
technical problem uh I'm going to be
doing more slides and less code but if
you want to see the demo come see me
after the code does run on my laptop
you're just not going to be able to see
it on the big screen
um I would like to start
um this talk with my favorite screenshot
of the past year this is flight
simulator which uh recently kind of got
an update I think a year ago or so and
um it's like super high fidelity
Graphics you can actually fly around the
world and when the game just came out
you could fly to Melbourne in a suburban
area and you would see this thing
um this was of course kind of popular so
a lot of people actually flew up quite
close and like you can see this like
giant uh you know overarching Tower with
the Epic Shadow and people were
wondering uh what developer did this how
did this happen so turns out
um this video game used a data set
called open street maps and open street
maps is one of these data sets where
volunteers can put in their own data and
there was a user called Nathan Wright
120 who accidentally wrote a bit of a
typo that house was by accident 212
stories tall instead of two
um but it did lead to this kind of
interesting funny moment it's kind of
like a data quality issue and this was
like one of those things where you could
kind of go ah kind of interesting data
quality is important because otherwise
we get this stuff
This was meant as a joke and now I want
to talk about the thing I actually want
to talk about uh which is bulk labeling
techniques and uh what I'm going to be
doing
um not live unfortunately is just show
some open source libraries and stuff
that I've been working on but the main
problem that I am going to be talking
about here is that let's say you want to
do a classifier you want to classify
something uh people swearing online or
whatever thing it is whenever you do
that you usually start out with a
situation where you've got some sort of
large unlabeled bucket of data
and you would really like to get to the
other end we've got some sort of trained
model that's at least somewhat reliable
and this is like the cold start problem
when you're starting with a model you
could say you don't always start with a
data set that's properly labeled
so what can we do here well one thing
you at least should do is make sure that
this doesn't happen
um this is the Udacity self-driving car
data set and everything in red is a
missing label so this is a data set
meant to train your own self-driving car
and you can see that the kit on the bike
hasn't been labeled there's a Ferrari
that's not been labeled there's a woman
with a stroller I'm sure there's also a
death truck
but this will be bad right if whenever
you're going to train a machine learning
model you don't want to end up with a
data set that has these sorts of issues
like this is the thing you got to
prevent before you actually get to your
model
um and you might think well this doesn't
happen all the time does it
um so there is this big data set called
scifar100 it's kind of like one of these
big Benchmark data sets that people like
to compare their algorithms on if you
were doing like computer vision 10 years
ago this was kind of like one of the big
ones
turns out they have a train set and a
test set that's official and there are
duplicates between them and not just
items that are very similar or near
duplicates according to this paper there
are exact duplicates between them
and I should stress this is a
benchmarking data set this is something
that you need to demonstrate against if
you want to claim that you're state of
the art
um also turns out that scifar uh
together with a whole bunch of data sets
also come with improper labels
um if you look to the photo to the upper
right those two Blue Jackets those are
that's not a motorcycle I think but that
is how it appears in the data set
and this matters right it's like if I
think about this whole step that I want
to go from data and then eventually to
my model I mean I am in this awkward
situation where yeah I can take my data
I can pre-process it I can model it and
then I can make some metrics that help
convince me that the predictions are
going to be good
but if the input data is bad
your predictions are going to be bad but
if you mess up the data your metrics
might still very well be shiny this is
kind of the optimal on paper broken a
reality problem if you have duplicates
yeah your accuracy numbers are going to
be great but it doesn't mean that your
predictions are going to be reliable and
this is also why I keep telling people
that maybe accuracy isn't enough we need
more to convince ourselves than these
metrics if we want to do this right and
if I'm honest it's actually pretty darn
scary like if we want our field to maybe
survive an AI winner we've got to get
this sort of stuff right I think
so if you're going to fix this
um yeah we can do more robust models
that's possible and yeah there are
pre-processing techniques that are
interesting but maybe we should tackle
the problem in the beginning of the
pipeline because otherwise all the issue
is just going to propagate forward
that's kind of my attitude and kind of
my thesis
I call the data problem we should also
maybe admit there's one thing that we
shouldn't do
and that's what I like to call the
Mechanical Turk effect which seems to me
like it's still a very popular thing to
do you just say hey I've got unlabeled
data I would like to have some labels
hey internet here's a bucket please
label it
um and if you want to read a good blog
post on what can go wrong there is a
blog post from my employer it's called
supervised learning is great it's data
collection that's broken it's from 2017
um so the blog has been out there for a
while and the blog basically describes
that if you have a labeling task and you
send that to possibly the other side of
the planet to a team of people who
doesn't share the same problem that you
do and you underpay them and you give
them a boring annotation interface
then maybe you shouldn't expect very
great data sets to start with and that
we also shouldn't be surprised that we
have pedestrians missing from
self-driving car data sets
so
hopefully that argument on its own is
compelling enough that maybe we
shouldn't trust like hey crowd let's
label this together and assume
everything will be great if you really
want to tackle this data quality problem
I think the only thing you need to do is
just annotate it yourself
that way you're confronted with your own
label quality and also the thing is you
can do this with a team that actually
cares eventually you are probably going
to have a model and that's hopefully
going to solve a problem and I don't
think a random person on the internet is
going to care as much about the solution
as you and the team that is trying to
fix it
and moreover as you're labeling you're
probably also learning about your
problem
this is also another reason why you
shouldn't just throw it out on the
internet because you're probably going
to have to iterate on your approach as
well
so we are going to be annotating and I
can imagine that if you've never done it
before you might be interested in some
tips
um if you really you've never done it
before and just want to get started
there is a very lovely plugin for
Jupiter called pigeon Jupiter Dash
pigeon pip installable code hasn't been
changed for five years because it just
works it's just a couple of IPython
widgets where you're able to give it a
list of things that you put a notebook
can render and you just get a couple of
buttons so you can just do
classification inside of your notebook
and if you're just trying to get started
this is great
um a couple of downsides I mean like the
moment you close down your laptop all
the labels in memory are gone so that's
a downside you also don't get keyboard
shortcuts but again like this is free
and you can just go ahead and use it
this is I think a very solid option
um if you're serious and I should admit
uh I'm uh take a grain of salt here I
work for the company that makes this
tool called Prodigy but there are these
labeling products that you can also
definitely go can go ahead and consider
some of the things that I like about
this is that the labels actually go to a
proper database there are lots of great
labeling interfaces not just
classification you can also just do
substring detection images audio all
that good stuff and it also comes with a
python API which means that you can do
whatever fancy Active Learning trick you
like
but no matter which of these two
labeling tools you have you still have
an interesting issue
and that is that there's maybe still a
step between that large unlabeled data
set and The annotation tool that you're
about to use
and this is especially true when you're
just getting started because for all
intents and purposes this might be like
a data set with like fraudulent examples
let's say
and maybe we have millions of examples
and only a few of them are actually
going to be interesting for the model
so maybe we don't want to go through
every single example by hand and for
that
um I like part of my job is to come up
with the some trick part of this diagram
there are some tricks that you can do
where you don't really need
um much or even any label data
but you can still work in such a way
that you can learn a lot yourself from
labeling but also in such a way the
model can learn relatively quickly and
the the problem definition that I am
going to follow is this is when you're
just starting out so all the tricks that
I'm about to show you are really good
for starting out I don't want to suggest
that they are amazing when you're
already you know two months working on a
problem but if you're really just
starting out there's actually a couple
of really nice hacks that you can do and
I would like to present a couple of them
albeit just in slides because the live
demo won't work but I hope that people
are understanding and excited about this
problem that we might be able to do some
good with this foreign
you just got a big data set let's say
it's text
well then let's then say that we have
newspaper articles just as a sort of
tangible example and I want to have all
the newspaper I don't have a classifier
that says is this new paper article
about sports let's say
well then
I can take all of my text
and I can index that in a search engine
no problem because I don't need labels
for that
the only thing that this is going to do
is just going to make sure that if I
come up with a word it can just very
quickly give me all the examples that
contain that one word
and if you're looking for a library to
do this lunar is a great library in
Python it's nice and minimal single
function you can store the index as a
Json file it's not necessarily super
fast or state-of-the-art but for a lot
of hacking yourself it's surprisingly
great just because it's a nice little
demo tool
have that uh you can just say well can I
come up with sports articles and you can
kind of go well tennis and football and
I'm going to come up with a couple of
sports titles and surely if I just throw
in a couple of good terms Championship
let's say
then whatever things I get back from the
search engine there's a good probability
that it will be about sports
and if you think about like a lot of
these text examples you can usually come
up with a couple of words that describe
the class very well
now note this is not going to be perfect
you are also going to get some examples
that aren't about this class but you are
going to get lots of examples and
hopefully let's say at least 80 percent
of them are going to be of interest
right it's a pragmatic way of going
about it
there's a downside of this though if you
think about it
so let's say I actually build a
classifier this way right so all the
sport names that I have
that I'm probably going to train a model
that at some point also just overfits on
those few terms
like it's really going to overfit on the
term football and the term tennis and
maybe it will have a little bit of
trouble recognizing that there are also
sports teams and maybe just the presence
of a sports team I'd also indicate that
it's about sports
so I'm actually interested in maybe
doing something like this
but in a way that I'm not just
constrained with the token something I
can kind of do a thesaurus kind of a
thing that'd be kind of cool
and this is where embedding tricks come
into play
um and it's pretty neat if we're lucky
though um I'm definitely going to do
some hand waving here and glancing over
lots of details but the whole idea is
that let's say someone trains a big
model out there they take all of
Wikipedia they take a sentence up to a
certain word and they try to predict the
next word let's say
um you can have a big pre-trained
Network and maybe the model learns
something it's General that you can go
ahead and reuse because words might be
used in similar ways
um there are also models out there these
days that train on more than just one
task
um if I remember correctly the universal
sentence encoder from Google uses a
couple of sentiment data sets and a
couple of newspaper article data sets
and they really just try to have lots of
tasks in there but also here you might
end up with a system that can kind of
learn a little bit from the text going
in and blend that with the label going
out and if the text going in is to some
degree similar to the text that you have
and if the labels that they've been
trained on are also somehow relevant to
what you're doing
then maybe the final layer in that
neural network has some potentially
useful representation that we can go
ahead and use
now I do want to emphasize we have to
get a little bit lucky here because you
know if let's say we have a model that's
trained on Wikipedia if your text is
very much unlike Wikipedia
you might still get a bad time
but one thing that is pretty cool these
days is that these pre-trained networks
are just abundant just go to hugging
face and there's like thousands of them
that you could go ahead and download
some of them are also pretty domain
specific you also have models that are
for the biomedical domain for example
but then given such a model here's the
trick that we can do we have that one
little uh potentially useful
representation and basically that means
that when an example goes in we have
some sort of array representation for it
so for text a we have an array of
numbers a let's say and we can sort of
make this mapping
so if
X or a and then for all of that
I can kind of do this thing where I say
what if text a is a sentence like
business stock market and the economy
which is not necessarily a newspaper
article that you would see but we do
have like words and maybe some
associations that we'd like to see in
our training data
and you can also maybe imagine that if I
take a similarity of those two vectors
let's say from from Vector A to B and
for Vector a to c and let's say that
Vector B is very similar to Vector a
then maybe the text of vector B is also
very similar
to a and that means that I might be able
to do selection that way
instead of doing like a proper index
where I use words and I have to find
exact matches maybe this can be a nice
little approximation as well
and it's actually kind of a nice little
trick that you could do with this
because what you could do is you could
just say let's come up with like a
sentence that sort of just should
summarize
um you know the category that I'm
interested in like the class
that whenever a new Point kind of comes
in
um you can say well uh we have one
sentence that's literally about World
News International Politics the other
sentences sports news Olympics and
football I mean the distance between
those two uh sort of class
representation vectors and the new
Vector coming in
you can build a classifier based on that
um just use scikit-learn K Nabors
classifier
so
I hope that people are like kind of
excited about this you know this is kind
of a cool little trick that you might be
able to do
but the even though these embeddings are
pretty powerful I do find myself in this
situation where I really want to iterate
quickly and I'm not necessarily
interested in learning a new framework
whenever a new embedding comes out so
it's great that we have jax Karis
tensorflow and pytorch but if I want to
try out the latest and greatest I really
wouldn't want to learn a new framework
just to give the new embedding a spin
so I had originally a demo which
unfortunately I cannot show you but what
I can do is uh just go to the GitHub
page and just show you the framework
that I'm talking about I wrote a package
called embetter which is just a very
pragmatic way to give you image
embeddings and text embeddings for
scikit-learn just as a single
scikit-learn pipeline component
um and I do need a tech guy to come back
downstairs in a bit because I don't know
what the uh uh shortcut is to uh full
screen but in a bit
so the light the live coding segment
right now is going to be me typing in a
URL
but the library is called embetter
uh
advisor there we go
um and we can sort of zoom in right
there we go
um so the way it works you just pip
install and better that's it and what
you can just go ahead and do is you can
say from from and better there's just a
couple of components there is a column
Grabber which allows you to just grab a
single column from pandas and then we
have sentence encoders and sensitive
encoders for text so typically just just
like with the count vectorizer you would
First grab the column such that you have
like a list of texts and then you can
just pass that into one of these two uh
models and you've got your vectors I
have a similar thing for computer vision
as well
um so I do have an image loader that can
load an image from a path that's then a
python image object you have a list of
that you pass that along to the pi torch
image encoder and there you go we also
support most of the computer vision
models this way as well so just as a toy
example which you can find online
um what you can typically do is you can
make like your embedding pipeline where
you grab a column you embed it and then
afterwards you just have a logistic
regression you can feed that to a data
frame a cycle learn fit predict but boom
this is a very quick way like almost a
one-liner to start playing around with
embeddings that's kind of what this
package is doing
um and we also have an image API that's
a little bit more elaborate again that's
because first I have to take the path
and then I need to turn it into a python
image object but then after that that's
going into the pytharch model and also
then you've got your vectors
um
uh this yeah the installing is the part
that takes long because some of these
models are pretty big but this has been
out for a couple of months
um and this is also something that you
can go ahead and play around with if
you're interested in making like a zero
shot classifier basically what you do is
you just come up with a data set like
this with like positive sentiment
negative sentiment and like a label for
each
um you can replace this with logistic
regression or you can just put a k
nearest neighbor thing in there but
there you go that's the pipeline that
you can go ahead and use and then you
can tune the confidence such as you only
get examples of the classes you're
interested in that's basically the
premise that's basically how this works
um there are still some features that
I'm going to be building for this
primarily right now there's no GPU
support just yet but I have had people
that said hey I want to use this on
Google collab so that's something I will
work on probably sometime next year but
this is a pip install away and you can
already go ahead and use this
what's the shortcut
Ctrl l
sweet thanks
um
so this wasn't the demo I was planning
on showing you but hopefully that little
uh thing on the side there kind of
paints a picture on how you can go ahead
and use this
um
but if I'm very honest
um like one thing maybe I should mention
that because I was in The Notebook that
I do want to mention uh on the I have
this one data set where I Benchmark this
and then I ask the question let's just
come up with four sentences
use the embedding trick for like a few
shot classifier with the K nearest
neighbor and then throw it against a
test set how much do I get right
and I think I got like a 74 accuracy
unlike the the four news classes
then I figured hey what happens if I
just train a normal logistic regression
bag of words model and how much labeled
examples do I need in order to get the
same performance
turns out I was about 500 examples
and there's kind of two interesting
lessons here I do want to mention like
on one hand you can say hey it's pretty
cool that we might not need to label
that much data to get a model that's
still reasonably accurate
and that's definitely like the thing I
was going for but at the same time I
also hope you realize 500 examples isn't
like a huge amount either like you can
also just label that yourself and it's
also still a very valid way to go about
this the bulk labeling tricks that I'm
mentioning here are primarily useful
when you have like a very imbalanced
classification problem where it's very
hard to find that one class that you're
going to be super interested in
so do remember what I'm presenting here
is just a trick you are still allowed to
just manually annotate data and that is
still a really good thing to do
that said
uh downside of this approach that I just
showed you because one thing I don't
like about it is you do have to come up
with like a very good sentence that
summarizes this one class that you have
and it kind of becomes a problem of well
we kind of have to do prompt engineering
which is kind of a hack
and then another thing I was kind of
missing is that maybe we can also just
be a little bit more visually oriented
so there's also this other package that
I made which is right now one of my
favorite tricks
and the package is called bulk you can
pip install it and it's meant to be used
with embetter and here's how it works
bulk assumes that you have a data set
like this tweets that CSV file and you
have some sort of way of embedding that
then I also assume that you've got
access to a dimensionality reduction
technique
in most cases
umap will be the thing you want you can
use principal component analysis PCA but
the downset of PCA is that it's really
good at keeping like the global
structure intact but it also means that
the Clusters have to be Global in order
to remain intact in your 2D
representation
umap on the other hand is much I would
almost say worse at keeping the global
thing intact but it's pretty good
keeping the local thing intact so
clusters of things that are close
together in like a local space Stay
Together in a two-dimensional
representation
but that means that I have a way to go
from text to two-dimensional coordinates
that are maybe clustered
and that's gonna be kind of interesting
because then what I can do is I can say
take all of my tweets and give me the
two-dimensional representation and then
I have this user interface where you're
able to make this selection on like a
cluster of points
and then you get this user interface
where you can just sort of see well if I
make a selection over here oh it seems
to be maybe about a certain topic and if
you can confirm that it indeed is about
a specific topic one that you would like
to pass on to Pigeon or Prodigy they can
just save these examples in a CSV file
and this is like purposefully minimal
like it really just has one button
that's the only thing you're supposed to
do with it it's meant for bulk labeling
but this has proven to be a trick that
actually works quite well
and because I'm better doesn't just
support
text but also images bulk can also
support images so if you have a computer
vision use case you can also go ahead
and use it
and this has gotten some attention like
people really like this idea which is
kind of cool
but we can go a step further and oh it's
such a bummer I can't show you this live
so you're gonna have to come to my
laptop after to see the live demo what
I'm about to show you but maybe the
technique behind it is more important so
I'll try to focus in on that
okay
let's consider once more how embeddings
are typically made right and I'll take
the image example here
sorry image goes in convolutional layers
and at some point we have a dense layer
near the end so not the layer with all
the classifications like the layer
before basically because that's a layer
that might be very appropriate for
embeddings right the some part of the
image is embedded in it some part of the
label as well
what I could do now is I could say how
about I just annotate 20 examples and in
the
um demo that I had which you can also
find online by the way
um I had pictures of cats and dogs of
different breeds and I wanted to build a
classifier for just cats and dogs so
what I did is I just labeled 20 images
for cats and 20 images for dogs
and then I extended this what I did was
I said well let's build a new task head
at the end and the idea is where the
orange line was the embedding Vector
before
I'm adding a new dense layer at the end
and then a final output layer and
instead of using that orange line I am
now going to be using
um like the second to last layer there
and why is that well
the idea is that uh let's say I'm using
exception that pre-trained model
I can keep that Frozen like somehow that
model is already capturing information
about the image that I'm interested in
because maybe shapes of ears get
detected I don't know but some stuff
gets detected that might be interesting
but what is going to be interesting to
my use case well that really depends on
my label so what I kind of want to do is
blend that embedding with the label that
I'm interested in and the way you can do
that is you just freeze the exception
Network add this one little task head
which is four lines of code and Keras
and then only update the weights of that
final task head
if you do this
the 2D umap space goes from looking like
that to looking like that
and if you squint your eyes a bit
the umap chart on the right might have
Global structure
because it turns out if you do this for
like a binary classification case in
this case right
if I recall correctly the top right
those were all cats
the bottom left those were all dogs and
there's kind of a line in between there
that you can almost interpret as if it's
like the certainty for belonging to a
certain class
and that's kind of nice because that
means that the examples where the neural
network is kind of uncertain about is
right there in the middle
and in the live demo which I can't show
you the images that are in the middle
those are like cats and pomerians with
the same shape of ear
somehow it cannot use that feature
anymore to make a distinguishing case
and again this is uh maybe 20 or 40 I
forget but not like this was done in two
minutes of labeling but by doing so
kind of have embedding based Active
Learning with a human in the loop
and that's a pretty neat trick
because you can do this
um if like if you're able to label just
a few examples you might be able to get
an embedding space that will help you
discover a bit because one another nice
aspect of doing it this way is that this
also helps with topic Discovery you can
literally hover over a cluster that you
see and just ask the question what's in
here maybe you learned something
interesting and maybe you also learn
something new about your problem
and that to me is very interesting as
well because I like having a human in a
loop whenever I'm doing these sorts of
things that also helps prevent a whole
lot of missing pedestrians
so
um if you're interested in the demo come
find me after I'll gladly show you in a
bit um the main thing I want to give to
you is like these tools are open source
I made these as experiments to sort of
help Prodigy users see if we can help
them with some new tricks the main thing
I do want to remind everyone as cool as
all these things are they are just
tricks
um if you want high quality data you
want to iterate with a team that cares
and that caring is maybe more important
than having it another pip installable
package in your tool belt also these
tricks are only meant to help you get
started I can definitely imagine if you
already have your first 1000 labels then
there are other techniques that are
probably going to be helping you more
than what I'm doing here
but still we have these pre-trained
models so we might be able to use them
to help ourselves label
finally there's also
there's also time for sub module
optimization is a really cool trick
Active Learning phrase embedding support
embeddings keyword retrieval neural
search there's tons of other stuff that
I'm working on but I do think bulk on
its own is ready for use and I would be
interested in getting feedback so if you
have any do uh do mention it online like
I actually get some time to work on this
um yeah that's actually also something
you do if you actually want to see the
demo that I couldn't do here go to
YouTube because uh part of my work is
also to make demonstrations of this
um and also if you're interested in
tutorials and like tricks to find bad
labels like labeling tricks I try to
document that for Prodigy users uh the
videos are designed in such a way that
even if you don't like to use Prodigy
you can still learn something from it so
if this sounds interesting definitely
check out our YouTube channel because
it's part of my job to uh to populate
this
great final plug
um the company I work for makes a tool
called Spacey and very recently we've
started also doing some consultancy on
the side this is great because it helps
us be a company that doesn't just make
the tool we also actually use it for
clients I can also confirm that it has
already caused a new couple of new
features tip here in the library and if
that sounds interesting to you please
come talk to me we also have a new
servers that was announced two days ago
called tarot analysis where we help you
with annotation practices and
consultancy around that
um I hope this was interesting thanks
for listening I have a bunch of stickers
if you're interested by the way so come
find me for that as well also some rare
exclusives from the Spacey team
um and then as a final comment if you
know this website also come talk to me
after because I have some questions
and and again it is such a cool demo
like completely to the stage later like
it's such a cool demo but I hope this is
also educational I think it's time for
some questions I guess so does anyone
have some questions for Vincent or a
data science joke
or some jokes or a joke
representation for the three blue one
brown uh uh oh yeah thanks yeah I'm
surprised that one thank you yeah
um have you tried to actually explore
the embedded space with the unsupervised
techniques like variational autumn
colors or because with unsupervised
techniques like tfidf and that sort of a
thing more than the because you are
using pre-trained models right yeah but
in a supervised way yeah
out of course to to generate like uh
so the question was are right now I've
mainly been talking about like embedding
techniques pre-trained models and such
and the question seems to be well can
you maybe also do something with count
vectors or tfidf or like unsupervised
techniques based on top of your own data
you totally can and it actually kind of
works the one thing to keep in mind is
that especially tricks like tfidf you do
end up with like very big sparse vectors
so the trick that I like to use is make
the big sparse Vector first but then
maybe uh pass it through SVD because
that's the algorithm if I could learn it
can actually handle sparse input it's
like PCA but for sparse stuff
um and that works quite well if you've
got longer documents too
um note that I'm saying this as an
English speaker it doesn't work as well
for other languages but for English and
Dutch it's actually quite reasonable to
try that out
in general though the longer the
sentence like the moment you go towards
like paragraphs or Pages this trick
works less and less well it's mainly
meant for like one or two sentences
or photos thank you
there are any other questions for
Vincent
great talk great talk
if you're going to Branch off from
Spacey and build your own classifiers
are you going to call it classy
um it's funny you mentioned that so I
actually maintain a couple of
scikit-learn plugins my token based
tricks are in a library called
tokenwiser
which I thought was cute but we also uh
matthiasis around here like there you go
um he's a collaborator with me on a
project called psychic Lego which has
Lego bricks for some striking learn
pipelines there's also some like
rule-based systems that you can build
using human learn
um and I also uh Pi Pi squat a bunch of
package names that are also going to be
interesting but that's uh the the I I
try not to have too many puns in the in
the library because people do have to be
able to find them
like I have this one neural search
library that I made the other day like a
year ago and I've called it SimCity it's
impossible to find because I thought it
was kind of cute like oh similarity
build your own City build a neighborhood
but then like no one can find it because
SimCity is heavily indexed and like
another thing online so
my GitHub page right uh if you say so
thanks yeah
right thank you for your talk
um please make sure that you're gonna go
see his demo and you see it's gonna it's
something I also I have to go in an hour
so if you want to talk to me so make it
fast people all right thanks again for
your talk Orlando Plus